[Musique]
je suis l'inspecteur kinder de scotland
yard j'enquête sur une série de morts
violentes
tina ça ça se fait appeler le golem arad
qui file massacre une famille la semaine
précédente une prostituée
le golem est complètement fou
même la folie à une certaine forme de
logique
l'inspecteur kildare et bien j'ai
peut-être trouver un témoin oculaire à
la masse qui se trouvait ici le 24
septembre et il y avait quatre hommes
dans la salle de lecture et journaux
disent que c'est votre première affaire
criminelle
je ne suis qu'un bouc émissaire pour ce
quotidien
le public veut voir du sang
et le collet moulante à celui qui
regardent sans rien faire ne reverse pas
moi le sens que celui qui infligent les
blessures
c'est un message à notre attention
le collet mais toujours dans la nature
perdre mon temps avec vous pourrez
compter défini
[Applaudissements]
le golem on a vraiment je vais y mettre
fin
je vous le promets nous portons tous des
masques
n'est ce pas